so we're going to talk a little bit
about um
about womanness
about womanness
because
um
katanji brown jackson who is biden's uh
pick uh to uh to be the next member of
the supreme court the united states um
who is you know
well qualified for the job she is she
has a an incredible i don't know if they
call it a cv in legal circles but an
incredible um
background um yeah i don't think it's a
cv i think it's a resume but yeah okay
um
but uh somewhat famously uh she was
asked in the hearings this week
uh if she could after a little bit of
back and forth if she could define what
a woman is and she said uh no in this
context she could not define what a
woman is because quote i'm not a
biologist
well um
lucky for all you we are biologists can
you provide a definition for the word
woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you
lucky for all you we are biologists
and uh we can define what a woman is but
i should say it doesn't take a biologist
to define what a woman is and uh before
you interrupt yeah all right i wanna i
wanna just say that i was going to seed
the floor because of course what it is
to be a woman is to be sort of
deferential
and to always let the man take the lead
and to um you know probably go clean
some stuff up or maybe make a cake or
something um that is
what it is to be a woman so
not an expert exactly though i'm gonna
explain it because that's what it is to
be a man but you're a biologist which is
the expert that we've been called on to
seek and we are both biologists and yet
clearly
your
madness should trump my womanness in
answering the question on account of
what now
well
all right let me start my interruption
and splaining uh discipline i'm going to
explain
i actually think her answer
was
perfectly justified
um
it's not that i think she couldn't have
given the obvious answer and that would
have been equally justified but at the
current moment i certainly understand
that
from the perspective of somebody for
whom this is not their
uh their core interest in the world that
being asked the question to define a
term like this you know it's not it's
not uh a simple well it is a simple
matter but it's not necessarily obvious
that it would be a simple matter because
people have raised all sorts of
complexities which i will point out are
irrelevant to the definition
so i'm going to interrupt you now but we
we're going to go back and forth a lot
because there's a lot to say here but um
i went ahead you know
first what rang in my in my ears uh was
kelly j keane right um the awesome the
awesome uh british feminist
also a woman um who also goes by uh
posey parker uh we've both been on her
show
um
somehow not a biologist and yet she
seems to have a really good grasp of
this
famously says adult human female adult
human
female right it's just not that hard so
i
didn't know if this was her formulation
so i went ahead and looked it up a few
places okay uh i went on to
dictionary.com
adult female person
okay
merriam-webster online also adult female
person and then i pulled out i went for
the big guns in fact i had to wake our
producer up this morning to pull out the
the oed okay so we happen to have a hard
copy
of the oed we actually had two hard
copies of the oed because both of our
parents got these for us when we were
children and at some point we're like
we're in this for the long haul we do
not in fact need two hard copies of the
oxford english dictionary in our home so
we only have the one at this point here
it is and this is of course
the box is falling apart um the second
the second volume this is p through z
plus the supplement and bibliography um
and their definition of woman
is um also just take a look at the at
the text here this is um it ain't it
ain't big women in this book have been
belittled along with everything with
everything else um
yeah uh and in fact rather than use the
handy
magnifying glass that they include i
have magnifying glasses built into my
eyes by virtue of being both myopic and
presbyopic at this point so i'm going to
read their definition of woman and it
goes on for a while but the very first
definition is an adult
female human
being
okay
um so wait i want to i want to leap in
and make a point i noticed uh i barely
saw anything on
the internet this week but neil oliver
tweeted something about basically
banking hard copies of books and uh
documentaries and movies and things that
can't be retconned right because what
does that sound retroactive continuity
so part of the problem how is
retroactive how did how i don't i don't
get that as the part of speech there but
okay well
let's just put it to you this way those
who wish to change the definition and
pretend that it was always defined in
some other way have lots of opportunity
on the net they do not have an
opportunity to go back and change some
book that's been collecting dust for
however many decades i was pleased to
find that the two most common
dictionaries online had basically the
same definition that uh that kelly j
king uses and that the oed has been
using right yeah for now
for now for now we have seen things like
uh the definition of vaccine changed uh
subtly um
in recent months and anti-vaxxer things
like this right all these things so
anyway hard copies of books are coming
back because they can't be changed
remotely yeah um so i know you you're
going somewhere you were you were busy
splaining stuff but i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm going to explain um just a little
bit more about this seemingly very
simple definition you're going to double
x-plane
yes i am
um
yeah yes i am um so adult human female
right yep there will be those then that
will say okay then you need to define
those three words
fair enough can do
adult
of reproductive age or post-reproductive
age in any organism right we talk about
juveniles we talk about adults um and is
the entertainment of reproductive age
yeah the is you know is the border going
to be somewhat fuzzy are there
differences even with the united states
about what the age of consent is you
know it is reproductive age at the point
of first menses or is it the point of
peak fertility and it's not peak
fertility but
the average age of first reproduction
is as it turns out for senescence
purposes yeah and given that we're just
marching that earlier because we're over
feeding and over harmonizing our girls
in particular then you know that's
that's changing harmonizing yes it's not
a word but
i just tried it out it doesn't really
work um but adult okay but you know
having attained um you know the i i
think i think probably this is gonna be
it you know the average age of
attainment of reproductive capacity in a
species um that does mean that there
will be species where adults um of males
and females are going to be different
right it's going to be
some years in some cases where usually
it will be
the females have attained reproductive
capacity before the males
human or person because we see both of
those in these very simple three word
definitions of what it takes to be a
woman with what a woman is
and you know there's going to be a lot
of ink spilled as to exactly what this
is but the simplest thing i would say is
any living organism in any living
organism in the genus homo is a human
okay you know that's going to exclude a
whole lot of humans and it but you know
in terms of like hmm
are we are we looking at a woman here
like if it's if it's a living person if
it's a if it's of a living organism in
the genus homo
that's a person you're looking at
those are pretty simple
female is going to be the one where
people get um
their panties in a wad
they're
knickers in a twist is the way we say
that without getting evicted from the
internet no but if we were across the
pond we would get uh evicted from you
know we'd have to just keep popping
across the pawn depending on which of
these we want to say
so um
female
okay adult human female is what a woman
is and that does hinge on what you take
to be the definition of female and
luckily this is a place uh where
biologists know a thing or two the
answer is not complex there's lots of
complexifying things around the edges
which i'm sure we'll get to talking
about
but the fact is that the female of a
species
is
that individual that can or will or has
in the past produce
eggs
eggs being gametes the sex cells
that are larger
than the other kind of gamete and tend
to be sessile
they're full of rich with cytoplasm and
they don't tend to move around much by
comparison uh the male of the species
produces gametes that are little and uh
tend to be mobile or motile in the
language of of sperm so in plants we
call them pollen and in animals we call
it sperm
but if you if you have or will or have
in the past
had the capacity to produce little tiny
zippy gametes then you're male
and therefore not a woman and if you
have or
will or have in the past had the
capacity to or could have had the
capacity to absent some other problem
produce larger cytoplasm rich
immobile largely immobile gametes than
you are female and thus if the other two
things apply if you are both an adult
and a human
you're a woman
so
a number of things one if i wanted to
i could throw all sorts of challenges at
the definitions you just gave please do
then well this would this would be an
exercise in sophistry and i think once
again we have to
um
recognize the central question here is
one of sophistry right the whole idea
that we are somehow compelled to define
woman a term that everybody knows the
definition of right
and a lot of people are now pretending
they don't
but the point is that we get dragged
into this
is the result of sophistry now i think
it's very important that we actually
respond in this case because um because
of the claim that it's because i'm not a
biologist that i can't answer the
question although again i will defend
that answer i think that was probably
the right thing for her to say
um because
the problem is a lay person does not
know what to do
with the meaning of the ambiguities
right in other words if i take uh you
know
let's say sarah from the bible
right okay is sarah a woman
i i don't know the bible i don't know if
you've picked a weird example here well
i've picked a person that we don't know
existed right she may be a bible story
okay and therefore she may be a
depiction of a an adult human female but
um that doesn't mean
that she is a woman or if the story is
the story of sarah and the bible include
her having born children
no no
the the person in the bible i'm not
picky i'm picking sarah because she is a
female biblical name right who shows up
in the bible i believe in adulthood
now if the story depicts her entire life
she is born which probably it does
then the question is is sarah a woman
well then we could get into pedantic
stuff about the fact that the story
depicts her entire life anyway i'm not
arguing any of this is important because
we all understand exactly how you deal
with that ambiguity under normal
circumstances if you didn't have enemies
trying to cloud the the issue
so my only point is we are being dragged
into a world of sophistry somebody being
dragged into a world of sophistry has
the right to simply refuse to
participate and that right will be
abused many people will refuse to answer
questions that we pose about important
things by claiming that we are engaged
in sovereignty they will be wrong we
don't engage in sophistry but but the
point is
in a in a
world of landmines
this answer that actually okay if we're
going to get technical about what a
woman is then maybe we ought to bring in
a biologist strikes me as a reasonable
answer the question as much as i would
have preferred her to say adult even
female right i would prefer it but i
think you know
for example
i saw
uh
eric tweeted eric your brother yes
tweeted a response to this and his point
was basically the one we are making this
is not a difficult question but he
included in his definition an exclusion
for intersex people which is absolutely
unnecessary right
i understand why he did it right because
there can be
ambiguities that blur boundaries you and
i would point to gametes as the defining
characteristic and nobody as far as we
know produces both gametes but even if
they did right that's not inconceivable
even if they did the point is these
nuances do not change the fundamental
definition and i would point as you and
i taught repeatedly
when we were professors
the fact that um
you cannot you know you've got a
mountain you've got a valley
at some point you've gone down the
mountain far enough to be in the valley
but there's no way to define what moment
that is does that mean mountains and
valleys are a social construct
no the river's in the valley it's not on
the mountaintop right so yeah you know
this this category though is a hell of a
lot less fuzzy than that i you know as i
have as i have said many many times many
places written written many essays on
this
you know
and as we as we have talked about as we
have written into the book and all um
you know gender is the software to the
hardware of sex sex is binary and yes
there are some
mistakes
in humans mistakes developmental
mistakes or genetic mistakes
but just like having zeros and ones in
your machine code
and then occasionally having missing
data or a question mark doesn't render
it non-binary sex is still binary gender
being the software of sex
um means you know basically the
behavioral expression of sex and are
there lots of you know art
do i have a lot of gender non-conformity
um in you know in part because i grew up
with a with a dad who did a lot of stuff
that i thought was really cool and i
wanted to you know do the kinds of
things he was doing yeah
does that in any way call into question
whether or not i'm either a woman or a
female no
it makes me perhaps less feminine
which might be the gender description of
sex stereotypical
traits
but that's fine and that says absolutely
nothing about the underlying reality of
whether or not i am a female or male
woman or man but you are hearing me say
something that i am not saying my point
is those rare exceptions exist even if
they were common it wouldn't matter
it is not necessary to include an
exemption for them because the
definition works as addition into the
passage of electricity uh through a
circuit
right but it is not hard to come up with
examples that you know
one could argue either way right
well i don't you picked an example that
i have
exactly zero history with i mean i've
i've built some electric circuits and
all but like you know you ask me
to define you know the distinction in
electric and electronic and you have
only defined one of them even so you
only did half the job here i don't i
don't inherently know i have a sort of a
gist of a feeling for what the
difference is but i really think that
you'll be in part because that is a a
human-made system
reasonable people can disagree
more compellingly than and not only is
the system human-made but the
categorizations are human-made and the
fact is that female
exists as a category completely outside
of whether or not humans exist because
what the definition of woman is includes
the word human in it human woman doesn't
exist outside of human right but it
exists outside and long before humans
ever had any idea of what it was and
frankly everyone knew it everyone people
who weren't wandering around going like
i don't know male female i can't tell
like no one was doing that right this is
not confusing right this is sophistry
but you are electric electronic you know
i feel like this actually plays into
their hands to be talking about systems
that are specifically um at least in the
case of electronic uh anthropogenic but
but i think again you're hearing me say
exactly the opposite thing that i'm
saying electric versus electronic is a
fair distinction even though there are
cases in which i can poise something
just on the cusp so it could go either
way like a
a telegraph key
right telegraph key just completes a
circuit over some long distance right
and it's used to send simple messages
right like we are under attack
so the point is it's
uh by its design it's an electrical
circuit but it's playing the role of an
electronic circuit and you could argue
it either way but the point is somebody
who would pull out that example and say
well you are falsely drawing a world of
electric versus electronic stuff right
that person would be engaged in
sophistry the point is there are a tiny
number of examples yes we could you know
use
we could agree
that a light bulb is electrical and not
electronic and then we could agree that
if i leave a particular light on that it
means something right so we can poise
things on that cusp without actually
challenging the fundamental nature of
definitions and the point is if you
apply the same standard the sophists are
using then we wouldn't be able to talk
about anything true absolutely true i
just think that it is
further confusing and further adding
fuel to the insane fire that is somehow
erupting around all of us now to use by
comparison uh to
an ancient truth a tr so
there have been two sexes for something
up to something between one and two
billion years with a b
whether or not our lineage has been
sexually reproducing that entire time is
not totally clear we can't go back in
time with that amount of of clarity
probably probably so but we can know for
sure for at least 500 million years we
have been we have been reproducing
sexually
so to say uh but okay here's some
examples from a sphere
that is you know electric exists outside
of humans but electronic doesn't uh and
you know we have created electronic
systems to be using two cad you know two
definitions one of which does exist
outside of humans one of which doesn't
it just muddies the waters i just i
don't feel that this is that this is a
useful comparison because it precisely
contributes to the idea that um you know
some of these people will call
themselves post-modernists some of them
will call they'll have lots of names for
themselves but you know the gender queer
you know lots of names
but the idea that you are what you say
you are that female is just a feeling
that humans can be
sequential hermaphrodites
no no and no
it's just entirely false of course which
is why i'm saying
the definition is adult human female and
saying something like excluding intersex
people
the definition is adult human female is
unnecessary because adult human female
covers it no matter what even if you had
somebody who produced both kinds of
gametes that you and i would agree is a
special case
[Music]